the word I always got was that Paul was
not open to suggestion about the music
but John was John was more open to if
you said hey I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do that he would listen Paul was more
exacting he knew exactly what he wants
you know we have to thank Paul for the
amounts of music we put out because he's
the workaholic right John and I'd be
sitting in the garden and the phone
would ring and we say we know it's him
we just knew by the ring he wants to go
to work hey should we go in the studio
lads all right and that's what we do so
he was the motivating force he was right
this song I want to be your man which
you have oh yeah
[Music]
The Beatles originally gave this song to
the rolling stolen stones they don't
understand that I thought they were your
rivals why would they give that so I
think that was just press I never felt
we were big rivals you know we were the
Beatles they were the Rolling Stone do
you feel that they always reacted to
what you guys were no I think Andrew
Loog Oldham set this like battle scene
with the press Norah's when I came to my
birthday here Radio City a few years you
know if we meet up we got dinner in LA
Ronny was there everybody was friends
everybody was friend it was an arrival
they gave them that song and then you
know we need a song kangho I'll let him
do that
what do they mean by that they need a
song for ring AHA because I have one on
each record
I know because with them I mean they
were writing them and doing them so I
just got one song how do you know that I
want to be your man is a Ringo song who
decides that if I do it it's a Ringo
zone right because it's the way I do it
and the way we did it do the guys come
to you and say does John say hey Ringo
this is your song for the album we hear
your voice on this and no he said you're
doing that you're right and when you
have never said it